My name's Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's one
and only Spiderman and things are going great
he's gonna be here any minute should be
simple enough give me your money so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian ah Spiderman
I am spot that's not funny don't do that
there's bubbles now hold on
I don't think I want this
costume anymore in a minute
hey wrote it all this one word that's
cute right the youth how's this going
a and AP Physics that's my little man
and a B in Spanish what okay miles
wanna get out of here welcome to spider
Society I'm Spider-Man oh no way all of us are
me Miguel O'Hara he's like a ninja vampire
Spider-Man but a good guy plus he's like
such a good leader miles there's moments in our
stories that are the same for all of us some good
did you bring our baby to another fight I knew
I was gonna regret making her that web shooter
you asked me not to so I didn't
I wouldn't it's in bed you have
a choice between saving one person and
saving every word to me that's an obvious
choice send me home I can't do that I
can do both all stations stop Spiderman
everyone keeps telling me how my story is supposed
to go nah I'm gonna do my own
thing can this day get weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run sorry
my bad everybody there was somewhere to run
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie there's a
brand new Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer with a whole bunch of new footage a
bunch of Easter eggs so we'll break it down if
you're brand new to the channel I'll also do a
giveaway for movie tickets soon because the movie
is coming out in a couple weeks so all you have
to do to enter that is just be a subscriber and
post all your favorite moments from the trailers
on the video just starting at the beginning of
the trailer they have a new scene of them in
the counselor's office with a new scene of him
fighting the spot for the first time the whole
idea is it seems like the spot has just gotten
his powers recently or not that long ago and he's
still trying to figure out how they work he's like
a petty criminal at the beginning of the movie
who's using his powers for small time things like
robbing ATMs inside bodegas in Miles Morales is
just laughing at him because he's been Spider-Man
for a little while so he's got a little more sure
of his powers they're even creating merch for
him like there's bootleg merge in his Universe
of him it seems like they have a couple different
fight scenes broken up across the movie like some
of this is funny from that first fight and then
there are scenes from them fighting much later in
the movie where it seems like the spot figures
out that he's actually way more powerful like
oh my Powers actually give me way more abilities I
can do way more than just robbing ATMs and bodegas
and that's where it escalates to him becoming this
Multiverse ending threat but in the next scene you
actually see what it looks like when Miles Morales
is fighting the spot traveling through one of his
Multiverse portals and it looks similar to the
Multiverse effect like they're traveling between
Dimensions between universes later in the trailer
you see a spot using his abilities this way and
he seems way more powerful way more of a threat
they have that new joke about him texting with
his parents while they're waiting for him at his
counselor meeting and he's not answering his text
like the three dots are just pending there because
he can't find time during the middle of his fight
to Finish the text cut to the real life Bubbles as
they're slipping through in his fight and notice
in the background too this is another funny moment
like this where he's on the subway where something
similar is happening all the people in Brooklyn
here like seeing Spider-Man fight a villain after
they both fall through a Multiverse portal in time
and space isn't enough to get a reaction out of
them like they could barely care they have the
joke about the little kid not wanting them Miles
Morales Spider-Man costume anymore because he sees
him botching the fight with the spot and he's less
impressed with him now it's a callback to Miles
Morales in the first movie getting the Spider-Man
Halloween costume as his first suit the little
girl wearing the regular Peter Parker Halloween
mask costume is foreshadowing for the spider army
with all the different versions particularly the
version of spider bite who he talks to later
in the trailer the same thing happened with
the original Peter Parker in this universe too
but like they have the Spider-Man comics in this
universe that Miles Morales himself read there's
even an Easter egg for one later in the trailer in
this universe those are meant to be biographical
stories about the life of the real Peter Parker
before he died the meeting here is about his
college track his school prospects based on his
grades the school he's going to is from the first
movies a special Magnet School like Midtown high
in the MCU with Tom Hall and Spider-Man where
the kids who do well at those schools tend to
go to very prestigious or ivy league universities
like Peter was trying to get an MIT like Iron Man
and he would have probably gotten in were it not
for him being Spider-Man and getting it all this
trouble with the Multiverse it'll be interesting
to see where Miles Morales wants to go to college
and where he winds up going because I think it's
going to be a very Spider-Man no way home kind of
thing where they want to keep the character in the
New York City area because you want to have Miles
Morales stories around New York City on his Earth
here's the thing about that timeline for Miles
Morales though within this spider-verse universe
he's only a second year during this there are four
years in American High School they said this movie
ends in a cliffhanger Empire Strikes Back style
like a wtfo crap there goes the Multiverse kind
of cliffhanger so the third movie is meant to be
kind of like a part two like Avengers Infinity
war and Avengers end game picking up immediately
after that Cliffhanger and it's called Spider-Man
beyond the spider verse which is why I like the
idea that that movie will set up Miles Morales
the other major spider-verse characters winding
up in a live-action Universe setting them up for
an Avengers Secret Wars Cameo when they all get
in that movie in the MCU and what'll probably
happen at the end of that story is that he'll
basically be done with high school and the next
Trilogy of miles Morales movies whether they be
live action or they continue to be animated will
be his story through college the same way they're
doing that with Tom Hall's Spider-Man character
starting in Spider-Man 4. and like I said in the
MCU they found a logical way based on the story
for him to have to stay in the New York City area
and do college there like Empire State from the
comics they'll also probably do something similar
with the Miles Morales character too Rey has to
stay in the New York City area while he's going
to college you also notice that his counselor's
name here is Weber as in spider web the number
42 Jersey is actually an Easter egg for Jackie
Robinson who played for the Brooklyn Dodgers
when they were in Brooklyn another cool MCU
connection is that Chadwick Boseman in real life
played Jackie Robinson in a movie the number 42
also appears all over the place during the first
movie it's even the number of the spider that bit
Miles Morales which was made by alcamex which is
where Spider-Man 2099 Works in his futuristic
Nueva York it's all connected we get a couple
longer new shots of the Spiderman Army Multiverse
base which is constructed like a literal spider
web with them walking all over the place spider
Gwen calls it the spider Society you notice behind
here too there are cages holding the Multiverse
villains that they've captured there's a much
better shot of Hobie Brown's spider Punk without
his mask on he's being voiced by Daniel caluya
who is also in the first Black Panther movie
so another MCU connection we get a much longer
funny scene of Peter B Parker in his Universe with
his version of Mary Jane and he's putting Mayday
Parker to bed joking about how he'd never take
her on a mission because it's way too dangerous
and you totally asked me not to do that which of
course is a lie because she's with him through
the entire movie he also jokes about creating the
web shooters for her so she can use her Spider-Man
based powers that she inherited from him like she
has the same powers that he has in the actual web
shooter is designed like a child's toy the whole
talk about saving one person versus saving the
entire Multiverse is the needs of the many versus
the needs of the few right out of Star Trek and I
think this is a reference to the spot's character
and what's going on with him why he becomes the
actual main villain of the story when Miles
Morales is arguing that he can still save one
person and everyone at the same time I think the
idea is that Miles Morales is trying to show the
spot some compassion and help him like something's
going wrong with the spot in Spider-Man 2099 just
wants to lock him up and treat him like a criminal
and it's a lot like the ark during Spider-Man far
from home to make another Tom Holland MCU
reference where in that movie he tried to
help the Sinister Six villains and Doctor Strange
just wanted to get rid of them so in this movie
Spider-Man 2099 is kind of like a more aggro
version of Doctor Strange during Spider-Man
far from home which is also funny because during
this movie Spider-Man 2099 literally references
Doctor Strange in MCU Tom Hall and Spider-Man for
messing up the Multiverse with the spell this is a
much longer scene of Spider-Man 2099's futuristic
city of Nueva York with them gliding through the
air outside you also notice they have a real life
Honda campaign ad shout out here there's a real
car you can actually buy right now they had to
pay the movie a lot of money to be included here
did the joke about spider cat attacking him when
he says his day can't get weirder then the cat
jumps him and it's a version of spider cat from
the Miles Morales game the character is Canon to
the Spider-Man PS4 Universe in Spider-Man PS4 is
the character in this movie so we know that that's
Canon 2 the spider verse and they just have the
joke about his Spider-Man Powers because he's a
cat he coughs up a hairball but the Hairball is
webbing the black and white Spider-Man speaking
to him here about not having anywhere to run
is actually Metro Boomin the musician he did
music for the movie like he wrote some songs for
the movie and apparently they also made him a
character in the film as well he's not from the
comics he is original to the movie I've already
talked about most of the billion different big
versions of Spider-Man that are in the spider
Army here but one of the few ones that I didn't
see before is spider UK he's standing here in the
lineup next to Spider-Man Unlimited pretty much
anybody who's ever been a version of Spider-Man
from the comics from any medium from the video
games everywhere is in this movie in some way
which is probably why there's Cameo scenes from
Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield Spider-Man and from
Tom Holland's MCU Spider-Man this last joke is
a Toby Maguire Tom Holland type of joke for the
train save and the fairy save in Spider-Man
homecoming where they could barely hold the
two halves together like where he could barely
stop the train and he could barely stop the two
halves from splitting this version looks a little
bit more like the 616 comic book Spider-Man and
I think that's why they're saying that in the
world of this movie the MCU is actually Earth
19999 because one of the versions in the movie
is based on the original real life Marvel comic
book Spider-Man you also notice that one of them
riding over his webbing here is even using the
spidermobile the original Peter Parker from Miles
Morales Universe also had a version of that in
his lair too and has actually something from the
classic Comics that Marvel sold his merch back in
the day like you could actually buy this in real
life there's a billion Easter eggs here like you
could watch this trailer 10 more times and still
find new stuff so there's anything huge that I
didn't talk about in the video just write it below
in the comments in the movies coming out in a
couple weeks so I'll start naming giveaway winners
for the the movie tickets soon everyone click here
for my brand new secret Invasion trailer video and
click here for all my new Guardians of the Galaxy
3 videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!